this is one of those kinds of questions
where part of the challenge is just
getting over the way that it's written
and you're like how do i even how do i
even sort out what's going on right
now i think in some ways you get an
advantage in that when they say this
right unlike the question i just showed
you
this kind of locks you in you're like
okay if i remember my processes right
there's only really one way to solve
this and then it comes down to just
arithmetic and algebra okay but the key
is getting the approach right
uh where people fell down as i flick
through the papers where people fell
down
was not in the arithmetic algebra it was
in the setup it was getting it from here
to what was your line of working and
then if you got that right you just went
for it
it was fine okay so when i highlight
this in green
what's the formula what's the result
that we're going to be taking advantage
of
10 feet up where theta is the angle
between the lines what's it equal to
absolute value of
m1 minus m2 on
one plus m1 m2 okay
does that make sense i just recall
based on the fact that it's absolute
value right uh
these two here these two here it doesn't
matter what order you put them in you
just kind of want to make it
convenient to you when you have a look
at these two lines they've been given to
you in general form
which is not very nice but it's not
impossible to work with them right
if i designate this lime one and i
designate this one mine too
just think for a second without doing
because we can do this right without
doing
any paper calculations what would we
have to do with this
to get the gradient out of it like don't
do it just tell me what we have to do
okay yep i suppose yeah i want to make
why this subject so i have mx plus b4
right so just for my sake
it's a good conversation like having it
just a quarter of the volume
okay let me say that again
i want to make y the subject so i mean
you can move y
across the other side i suppose i
personally think about moving the
x over to the other side i don't care
about the constant because it doesn't
affect the gradient right
so this is going to become what on the
other side would be minus ax
and then to get mx plus b i'm just going
to divide by
three right so without having to write
anything down bam i have a gradient
do you see what i've done right these
are the little time saving things if you
ran out of time it was a short
space of time these are the kinds of
things where yes it's okay like look at
the number of marks
are they really trying to determine
whether you can manipulate an equation
no they're not
they're trying to say once you've got
this can you do this part this is what
we're assessing
right so this is where you're trying to
work out ah where do i put extra lines
of working where can i skip over it
right
where is it critical to the question in
exactly the same way
what gradient you're going to get out of
this
i'm going to move this guy over it'll
become minus ax right and then
you divide by -2 so the negatives cancel
so as you've just told me
a over two all right happy so now
i can compute this right i've got two
pieces of information
well i should say three pieces of
information to fit into it number one i
know what tan theta is
so i can just say two and then over here
on the right hand side i'm just going to
feed in my two gradients
okay now because like i know i've
written m1 and 2 m1 m2
but because of what i said the absolute
value i can be a bit loosey-goosey with
them you're going to get the same result
either way
the angle between the two lines is
always going to be the angle between the
two lines
this absolute value just gives you do
you remember why we do absolute value
which angle are we after we have the
positive result which gives the acute
angle
for tan because it keeps you in that
first quadrant is this ringing bells
okay
so being that i can do it either way i'm
just going to put the positive one first
because i can so i've got a over 2 minus
negative a over 3 all over
1 plus
okay you happy with that all right
suggestions what should i do at this
point
think what mental strategy would make
this easiest
to work
directly would make it the easiest if
you can for those who can't like me
i'm going to get rid of all of these
messy fractions gross
okay so what am i gonna get
oh five okay so so what's going to
happen on the top
this is going to become three
a plus plus
two a okay double negative right
what's happening on that denominator
this becomes a six
and then this minus becomes minus a
squared uh sorry yes that's right okay
all right so you're happy with that okay
now
when i have a look at this
i've got an absolute value of something
is equal to two is equal to two so if i
said to you the absolute value of x is
equal to
2 right this means that x can take on
two values
right because absolute value you've got
that reflection right
what two values can x take it can be
plus or minus two does that make sense
this is a spot that people fell down on
because a lot of people saw oh cool i
have a positive over here
i have a positive over here i can just
ignore my absolute value signs
answer no you can't because you don't
really know that this is positive
who knows what a is if you choose the
right a it'll be negative
right actually all you need to do is a
being negative
so therefore in order to get rid of this
absolute value sign i have to say plus
or minus
two three and then on the top you've got
five
a six minus a squared
b okay yes all right so a a can't be
plus or minus root six hooray
all right now thankfully thankfully
given the number of marks that wasn't
something they really paid us introduced
so you missed that out
um then it's no big deal okay uh really
it would have come in
here i suppose but aside from that okay
now at this point i think we've done all
the hard work really
i think i think that was the hardest
part of the question if you got here
students who got to this point
pretty much got it the big traps are all
gone okay but just in case you're
um curious what direction does this go
in it's a plus or minus so what that
really means is i'm solving two
completely separate equations right i've
got this guy
five a and six minus a squared equals
minus two that's case one um or
five a on six minus a squared equals
positive two and that's case
two right um you'll get your solutions
out of that and as you can see
because this a squared disregards this
sort of takes out the effect of whether
it's positive or negative or not
he doesn't care up here the difference
between 5a
giving you a negative and 5a being
positive is the solutions you get out of
this will just be plus or minus each
other
that's all you're going to get so once
you've converted these into a quadratic
you solve that's how you get to your
four
solutions plus or minus
one and a half plus or minus
okay